[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زواياه ومن جميع
جوانبه نبدا بالعناوين
مكروم منخفض الشعبيه يواجه الملايين في
الشوارع بلانيه للعوده عن قانون التقاعد
بيلاروسيا تتحدى التهديدات الغربيه وتؤكد
نشر الاسلحه النوويه الروسيه على اراضيها
والعقوبات في انتظار
عائق كبير امام ارسال الذخائر لاوكرانيا
في حربها ضد روسيا صدق او لا تصدق تيك توك
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
في القاره الافريقيه المهمه صعبه والصوره
الذهنيه عائق
[موسيقى]
الاحتجاجات تجتاح اماكن عده في العالم
بدانا الساعه يوم امس بتظاهرات في اسرائيل
احتجاجا على مشروع قانون الاصلاحات
القضائيه اليوم نبداها من تظاهرات فرنسا
وبسبب قانون ايضا هذه المره خاص برفع سن
التقاعد اقرته الحكومه دون موافقه
البرلمان ولليوم العاشر على التوالي يملا
الفرنسيون الشوارع احتجاجا على القانون
اليوم فقط اكثر من مليونير محتج بسبب او
بحسب النقابات العماليه منهم نصف مليون
فقط في العاصمه باريس
[موسيقى]
ورغم هذه التظاهرات اكدت رئيسه الحكومه
الفرنسيه اليزابيث بانه لا تاجيل للتطبيقي
نظام التقاعد من جهاته طالب المتحدث باسم
الحكومه الفرنسيه اوليفيا كل الاحزاب
والقوى السياسيه بادانه العنف مضيفا ان
الحكومه تحترم الاضرابات والتظاهرات
نحن نحترم الاضرابات والمظاهرات ولكننا
سنكون يقظين بشكل خاص للتاكد من انها لا
تؤدي الى اندلاع اعمال عنف جديده وهذا
بفضل التعبئه الاستثنائيه لقواتنا
الاماميه التي نحييها ونحيي كذلك الالتزام
افراد الامن التابعين للمنظمات النقابيه
احترام التظاهرات يعني الاعتراض على العنف
وادانته واولئك الذين يحاولون منحهم شكلا
من اشكال التبرير لا يحتدمون ناخبهم ولا
المؤسسات التي اقسموا على خدمتها وحمايتها
من جهه قال وزير الداخليه الفرنسيه جيرال
دارمانا انه سيطلب في اول اجتماع لمجلس
الوزراء حل مجموعه توراه الارض اليسريه
البيئيه المتطرفه وذلك خلال كلمه امام
مجلس النواب
وحملت الشرطه مجموعه ثورات الارض
المسؤوليه عن بعض اعمال العنف التي حصلت
مؤخرا خصوصا في سانسولين جنوب غرب فرنسا
وزير الداخليه اشار الى انه سيتقدم بحل
الاحتجاجات في اجتماع الوزراء المقبل
ارى العنف الشديده لبعض المجموعات الصغيره
كما ترونه انتم والتي اظهرت اجهزه
المخابرات انها مسجله منذ سنوات عديده
كمسؤوله عن اعمال عنف كبيره ومسؤوله عن
عمليات ابتزاز قويه ضد قوات النظام وتدمير
الممتلكات ووقوع مئات الجرحى من رجال
الشرطه نتيجه لتدميرهم لذلك قررت الشروع
في حل للاحتجاجات والذي ساقترحه في جلسه
اجتماع مجلس الوزراء المقبل
مشروع اصلاح نظام التقاعد يرفع الحد
الادنى لسن التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عاما
يفقد بعض العاملين في القطاع العام
امتيازاتهم
يرفع عدد سنوات العمل المطلوبه للتاهل
لمعاش تقاعدي كامل لماذا يهتم الفرنسيون
كثيرا بقانون التقاعد ينظر اليه كحجر
الزاويه لنموذج الحمايه الاجتماعيه
يدفع العاملون رسوم الرواتب لتمويل معاشات
المتقاعدين
يحصل جميع العمال الفرنسيين على معاش
تقاعدي
تعد فرنسا من الدول الاوروبيه التي تعتمد
ادنى سنا للتقاعد
حاول كافه الرؤساء المتعاقبين اجراء
تغييرات على قوانين التقاعد
غالبا تشعل غضب الشارع وتنعكس سلبا في
صناديق الاقتراع
وينضم الينا من باريس مدير مكتب العربيه
في فرنسا حسين قنيبر اهلا بك معنى ليلى
حسين يعني اليوم هو العاشر من ايام هذه
الاحتجاجات بسبب قانون التقاعد الجديد في
فرنسا هلا لخصت لنا هذا اليوم كيف صار منذ
بدء الاحتجاجات والان ما هو الوضع
مساء الخير يا راويه لنبدا بمن انتهى اليه
هذا النهار من قرار صدر عن تحالف النقابات
الرئيسيه التي تقود هذا التحرك الشعبي منذ
مطلع هذا العام هذه النقبات قررت الليله
يوم تحرك شعبي واسع النطاق سيكون موعده
الخميس المقبل في السادس من نيسان ابريل
هذا اليوم هذا النهار كان بدا بتجمعات عبر
كل فرنسا من باريس الى اليوم ومارسيليا
ومونبوليي ونيس وكان وتولوز
وبوردو
وعدد اخر من المدن المتوسطه او الصغرى
وكانت التظاهر المركزيه في باريس انطلقت
عند الثانيه من بعض الظهر بتوقيت المحلي
من ساحه الجمهوريه
باتجاه ساحه لناسيون ساحه الامه وهذه
الساحه تشهد الان بعض المواجهات المحدوده
بين الشرطه ومن بقي من المتظاهرين بعضهم
ينتمي الى مجموعات بلاك بلوك الفوضويه من
اقصى اليسار بل من اليسار المتطرف وبعضهم
من المتظاهرين الناشطين الشريحه الاكبر من
المتظاهرين غادرت ساحه الامه هو كان هذا
النهار شهد مواجهات خصوصا في ليل شمالا في
نوت غربا في بوردو في الجنوب الغربي
واليون في الجنوب الشرقي طبعا كانت هناك
تبادلات كان هناك تبادل للاتهامات بين
الحكومه من جهه والنقابات والاحزاب احزاب
اليسار تحديدا من جهه اخرى بعد ان اكدت
اليزابيث بورن خلال اجتماع ان تراسه
ماكرون في قصر الاليزيه يوم امس انها
منفتحه على حوار مع النقابات في الايام
المقبله وانها ستستقبل قاده احزاب
المعارضه مطلع شهر المقبل عادت اليوم
لتؤكد ردا على اقتراح النقابات قيام وساطه
بين النقابات والحكومه قالت الوزراء ان اي
شيء لن يغير من واقع ان قانون رفع سن
التقاعد لن يعلق وسينفذ هذا اعاد الامور
الى دائره المراوحه رد
زعيم اقصى اليسار احد ابرزعماء حركه فرنسا
الابيه بالقول ان على اليزابيث ان ترحل هي
واصلاحها اي هي واصلاح التقاعد نظام
التقاعد وقال المتحدث باسم الحزب الشيوعي
ايضا طالما اننا نتحدث عن مواقف اليسار
المتحدث الشيوعي قال ان المكسر الاول
والمخرب الاول في فرنسا هو قصر الاليزيه
ردا على اتهامات لجماعات يساريه باللجوء
الى التخريب خلال التظاهرات راويه
حسين انتهى وقتي ولكن سؤال يعني سريع جدا
موقف النقابات من اعمال العنف التي حصلت
اللي هي من اليمين واليسار المتطرف او
البلاك بلوك
طبعا هم يقولون انهم يدينون العنف من اي
جهه اتى لكنهم يرون ان العنف يكونوا
احيانا في الشارع ردا على عنف تمارسه
الشرطه فيما رد وزير الداخليه في تصريحات
مفصله امس قائلا انه منذ السادس عشر من
هذا الشهر وحتى مساء امس جرح 891 دركيا
وشرطيا في اعمال عنف قام بها انصار اقصى
اليسار وانصار اليسار المتطرف اذا اتهامات
متبادله بين الشرطه من جهه
والنقابات واحزاب اليسار بشان المسؤوليه
عن اعمال العنف راويه شكرا جزيلا لك من
باريس مدير مكتب بالعربيه في فرنسا حسين
قنيبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لكن هل هنالك حل يلوح في الافق للازمه في
فرنسا رئيسه الوزراء اليزابيث بورن اكدت
في وقت سابق ان لديها هدفين اجراء مشاورات
من اجل تهدئه البلاد بجانب تسريع
الاستجابه لتوقعات الفرنسيه واعلنت ان
حكومتها ستبدا سلسله واسعه من المشاورات
على مدى ثلاثه اسابيع مع الاحزاب السياسيه
ونواب وممثلين محليين وشركاء اجتماعيين
اذا ارادوا ذلك
المتحدث باسم الحكومه هو الاخر اكد فكره
الحوار قائلا انما كروم مستعد للنقاشات مع
الاتحادات النقابيه
يمكننا التحدث مع بعضنا البعض مباشره
قالها رئيس الجمهوريه انه مستعد لاستقبال
الاتحادات النقابيه بمجرد ان يعلن المجلس
الدستوري دستوريه نص القانون بعد ذلك يكون
رئيس الوزراء جاهزا لاستقبال النقابات
بشكل مباشر لماذا من المهم القيام بذلك
لانه بالفعل الى جانب اصلاح نظام التقاعد
وقد تحدث رئيس الجمهوريه عن ذلك هناك
العديد من الاشياء التي تحدث والتي تتعلق
بالعمل والتي تهم الفرنسيين
لكن السكرتير الفيدراليه لسكك الحديد في
فرنسا رد على هذه الدعوات نرفض التفاوض مع
ماكرون فما اسبابه نستمع
[موسيقى]
واعمى منذ نحو شهرين متجاهلا غضب الشارع
والمظاهرات والان ومع اقرار القانون يوافق
على مقابله نقابات لمناقشه الاجنده
الاجتماعيه ما لا يفهمه والحكومه هو ان
القوى العامله ترفض المضي قدما حتى يتم
التراجع عن بنود هذا القانون
وينضم الينا من باريس حول هذا الموضوع
الباحث في الاقتصاد السياسي الدكتور
دانيال ملحم اهلا بك معنا دكتور دانيال
يعني الى اين وكيف ستنتهي هذه الاحتجاجات
المتصاعده في الغضب
من قبل الشعب
الفرنسي يعني نلاحظ بان هناك تراكمات
وهناك غضب كبير من ان كان الحكومه من
مكروه ومن الوضع الذي الت اليه الامور
اقتصاديا
تحيه لك يا سيدتي والمشاهدين الكرام
ورمضان كريم
الى اين سوف تتجه الامور نعم الوضع اليوم
من الصعب من الصعب جدا ان يتوقع احد الى
ميله الامور هناك نوعا ما هناك تصلب من
ناحيه الحكومه وهذا مفهوم لماذا هذا
التصلب بهذا الخيار وبهذا القانون التقاعد
وهذا الاصلاح الذي اصبح لزوم اللزوم سريع
لعمليا للعوده الى ما يسمى او الانضباط
المالي الفرنسي اصبح عمليا مهم جدا
لمعالجه مشكله الانتاجيه نتيجه نمو ضعف
نمو الديموغرافي في فرنسا ولكن المشكله
الاخرى ان ان الشعب الفرنسي نتيجه اخطاء
ما تراكميه من ناحيه الحكومه في طريقه
التواصل مع الشعب وشرح اهميه هذا الاصلاح
زاد الغضب شيئا فشيئا ولكن الاحزاب ايضا
المعارضه سواء كان في اليسار او اليمين
متطرف تلعب دور غير مسؤول اليوم عمليا
بتحفيز اكثر الشعب والوق في وجه هذا
القانون دون وضوء او وضع على الطاوله
قوانين او قانون قوانين او اقتراحات اخرى
تساهم في تعزيز موقف هذا القانون
لذلك اليوم لا خيار امام الحكومه هذا
القانون لا تراجع عنه سوف عمليا نحن نصل
الى اليوم الى ذروه الشارع بدانا اليوم
نشهد تراجع نوعا ما في في النزول الى
الشارع يجب الانتظار الى الخميس المقبل
ماذا سيحدث وبالتالي هذا مراهنه الحكومه
على هذا الموضوع ولكن اليوم سيدتي ان لا
تراجعوا عن هذا القرار لانه هو حاج
استراتيجيه لفرنسا نتيجه العوامل
الشعب دكتور دانيال يعني حتى انه نلاحظ
بانه الاوضاع انفجرت ليس فقط بفرنسا
انفجرت ايضا في المانيا ايضا في بريطانيا
وكانه عده دول اوروبيه المواطنين فيها
يشعرون بان الاجتماع العداله الاجتماعيه
بخطر
صحيح الامور في المانيا وبريطانيا هي فعلا
مواضيعنا ناتجه عن التضخم ومطالبه برفع
اسعار برفع الاجور في فرنسا الموضوع ياخذ
طابع سياسي اكثر فيما يتعلق في اصلاح على
المدى الطويل هذه الاصلاحات هي موجوده نحن
نرى في المانيا ان نظام التقاعد هو هو 65
سنه وبالتالي هناك اصلاحات كبيره جدا في
هذا الموضوع المؤسف اليوم ان ان في هذا
القرار الذي تطرحه الحكومه هو قرار غير
مكتمل هو يتعلق فقط في العاملين وكيفيه
تمويل الاجيال القادمه وينسى الجانب الاخر
المتعلق في المتقاعدين نفسهم الذي يعيشون
في جنه ضريبيه الذي يعيشون في جنه
وبالتالي هذا القرار لم يطلعهم
نعم سيدتي اليوم التضخم في فرنسا نتيجه
حزمات الحكومه وحزمات الدعم الكبيره لم
تشعر فيه المواطنين بشكل كبير هو في معدل
في متوسط سبعه بالميه مقارنه بالمانيا
التي وصل الى تقريبا تسعه وعشره بالميه في
دول الشمال هو 15 و20% ونحن ننتظر عمليا
في النصف الثاني من السنه انحدار كبير في
التضخم في فرنسا وبالتالي التضخم ليس
العامل الرئيسي الذي يدفع التحركات
الشعبيه على الرغم من ان التاكل في القدره
الشرائيه عمليا هو يلعب دور وليست دور
الرئيسي هناك بعض المطالبات اليوم الاحزاب
السياسيه تلعب على هذا الوتر تلعب على وتر
ان هذا النظام التقاعد يريدون اصلاحات في
نظام العمل ورفع الاجور للشركات وهل هذا
الحكومه لن تستطيع عمله اليوم لان نقل
الاجور يؤدي عمليا الى زياده في التضخم
والدخول في حركه اجور واسعار وبالتالي هذه
يصعب التحكم فيه في المستقبل لذلك
المطالبات اليوم لا ترقى الى ادخال
تعديلات ولكن
سنتحدث ونكمل فكرتك اعذرني على المقاطعه
ولكن ابقى معي سنذهب لنتحدث عن نتائج
الاحتجاجات الواسعه الكبيره والمؤثره
فجامعوا القمامه مثلا مضربون منذ ثلاثه
اسابيع وصل حجم النفايات المتراكمه في
الشوارع الى
سبعه الاف و828 طنا لكن نقابه عمال
النظافه في فرنسا اليوم اعلنت تعليق
اضرابها في باريس اعتبارا من الغد لكن
تعليق بهدف هو التنسيق مع العمال حتى يمكن
لهذا الاضراب مره اخرى ان يكون بقوه اكبر
حسب ما قالته النقابه
التاثير الكبير وصل الى شعبيه الرئيس
مكروم الذي التي سجلت ادنى مستوياتها في
اربع سنوات وفقه ما اظهره استطلاع
للراي اجرته شركه بي في اي ونشرت نتائجها
اليوم اظهرت النتائج ان 28% فقط من
الفرنسيين الذين شملهم الاستطلاع راضون عن
اداء ماكرون كرئيس ادنى مستوى على الاطلاق
منذ نسبه 26% خلال حركه السترات الصفراء
في نوفمبر من عام 2018 بحسب الاستطلاع
ايضا غالبيه الفرنسيين بنسبه 70% يعارضون
تبني مشروع قانون لرفع سن التقاعد فيما
يؤيد 64% بشكل كامل الاضرابات والاحتجاجات
ضد الاجراءات الحكوميه
الرئيس وحيد يعاني من مرض عقلي يسمى
النرجسيه الشعب يريد اسقاط ماكرون
في فرنسا لم نعد في ديمقراطيه ماكرون يجب
ان يرحل والا لن تجد فرنسا السلام
الى شعبه ولا يكترث ولا يستمع الى النواب
في مجلس النواب هناك فوضى وفي الشارع كذلك
لا اعرف شعبيته في عموم فرنسا لكن من محيط
الشخصي من الشباب انه غير محبوب على
الاطلاق
الامر
[موسيقى]
اقول لكم بمسؤوليه انا لا اتطلع الى اعاده
انتخابي لا يمكنني دستوريا لكن بين
استطلاعات الراي والمدى القصير والمصلحه
العامه للبلاد اختار المصلحه العامه
للبلاد واذا كان من الضروري تحمل ان اخسر
الشعبيه اليوم فسوف اتحملها
جديد ينضم الينا الباحث في الاقتصاد
السياسي الدكتور دانيال ملحم اهلا بك من
جديد دكتور يعني شعبيات ماكرون كما نرى
تاثرت من هذه الاحتجاجات الرجل ايضا مستعد
لتحمل التكلفه مثلا الذي سيدفعه ايمينيال
مكروم بالانتخابات القادمه
اعتقد خساره
خساره اغلب اعضاء السنه التي الذين لا
يزلون يدعموها اليوم نحن امام مفترق طريق
من المحتمل ان يكون هناك تعديل وزاري قريب
جدا واما ان يدخل في مرحله حل مجلس النواب
وبالتالي يخسر يخسر الجزء الكبير من
الكتله النيابيه الداعمه له ولكن اعود فقط
سيدتي لنقطه معينه ان اليوم الخيارات
المتاحه امام الرئيس الفرنسي ليس بكثيره
وامام الشعب الفرنسي ليس بكثيره هناك
خيارين لثلاث لهما يا اما الدخول في
اصلاحات اذا كانت فرنسا سوف تستمر بوجودها
في نادي الخمسه او نادي العشر الدول
القويه وثاني دوله قويه بعد المانيا في في
اوروبا يجب الدخول هذه الاصلاحات لسبب
واحد ان اوروبا ان فرنسا هي راس حربه
المشروع الاوروبي وبالتالي عمليا هناك بعض
المعايير وقوانين الانضباط المادي
الاوروبي لا يمكن القول ان فرنسا اليوم
التلميذ الغير ناجي يخرج قواني الانضباط
المالي الاوروبيه وبالتالي هذا الاصلاحات
اصبحت حاجه
الخيار الثاني الموجود امام مفرزه هي
تعديل قانون الهجره وبالتالي عمليا
استقطاب مهاجرين لنقص عمليا الضعف في
النمو الديموغرافي الفرنسي باعتبار ان
النمو باعتبار ان اليمين المتطرف هو
يتصاعد بشكل كبير في فرنسا الخيار الثاني
شعب صعب لم يكن تمام
الخيار الاول هو هذا الاصلاحات هذه
الاصلاحات يعني بما انه عم تقول انه هي
ضروريه واصبحت حاجه للاقتصاد وللاجيال
القادمه لماذا لم تقنع الحكومه وامان
والماكرون النقابات والناس بذلك يعني هناك
مشكله
اعتقد سيدتي هنا وضعت الاصبع اصبعك على
الجرح الفرنسي بالضبط هذا هو خطا الحكومه
واعترف فيه الرئيس خلال مقابلته الماضيه
انه هو عمليه التواصل مع الشعب واقناع
الشعب والشرح والاخذ الوقت لشرح للشعب
اهميه هذا لهذا القرار لم ياخذ وقته بشكل
كافي تسارعت الامور بشكل سريع واتخذ
القرار عمليا باستخدام الفقره الثالثه من
المده 49 وادى الى الامر اليوم اعتقد ان
الشعب الفرنسي لو اخذ الوقت بالشرح له سوف
يبدا سوف يتفهم لانه هناك نوع من
المسؤوليه اليوم شعرت الشعب الفرنسي انه
هناك من يريد ان يفرض عليه وهناك حساسيه
مفرطه في فرنسا تجاه هذه النقطه لذلك
اليوم
التنفيس في الشارع او رده فعل الشارع هو
نتيجه الشعور بهذا الغضب اكثر ما هو عمليا
بالامور الاخرى على اعتبار ان لوروم بيرجي
عمليا على راس النقابات تفهم بالقانون وهو
يريد النقاش وطلب موعد من الرئيس للنقاش
بعض جنود والتعديل على هذا البنود
وبالتالي ليس كل النقابات هي رافضه
بالمطلق هناك البعض يتفهم الاحزاب اليمين
كلها حتى عمليا على راسها في برامج
الانتخابات الاحزاب اليمين حتى اليمين
المتطرف كان هذا القانون على برامجها
وبالتالي هي ليست ضد بالمطلق اضف انها هي
لمصلحتها اليوم تعرف ان رئيس ماكرون لم
يتراجع ولمصلحتها اليوم هو ان يقر هذا
القانون لانه لن تريد حمل كره النار في
المستقبل وتكره في المستقبل عندما يصبح
حاجه مطلقه بالنسبه لفرنسا شكرا جزيلا
لك من تتابعونا معنا بعد الفاصل كم تحتاج
الولايات المتحده لتعويض نقص مخزونها من
الاسلحه الجواب بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قال رئيس الوزراء
البولندي ماتيوس مراوسكي ان بيلاروسيا
ستتعرض لعقوبات بسبب وجود الاسلحه النوويه
الروسيه على اراضيها
هذه الخطوه التي اتخذتها روسيا والتي
تتمثل في الوقت الحالي في الاعلان عن نشر
اسلحه نوويه في بيلاروسيا ستؤدي بالتاكيد
الى اعلان عقوبات اضافيه وسيكون مستوى
العقوبات اشد بكثير على نظام لوكاشنكو
وزاره الخارجيه في بيلاروسيا اكدت انها
سوف تتخذ
اجراءات قصريه اتخذتها الدول المجاوره من
الاعضاء في النيتو
[موسيقى]
من هذه الحدود جنت روسيا عمليتها العسكريه
الخاصه في اوكرانيا ومنها تعزز قدراتها
الدفاعيه وبها ستنتهي من بناء منشاه تخزين
للاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه في الاول من
يوليو المقبل انها بيلاروسيا هذه الدوله
الشرق اوروبيه التزمت الصمت لايام بعد
اعلان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
للاتفاق على نشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه على
اراضيها هي في كلا الحالتين الحليف الاكبر
لموسكو بل انها قد تستعد بشكل مباشر
للدخول في الحرب الاوكرانيه وفي سبيلها
لذلك بررت نشر رؤوس نوويه روسيه بالمخاوف
المشروعه حيث اكدت وزاره الخارجيه
البيلاروسيه في بيانها ان البلاد سوف تتخذ
اجراءات ردا اضطراريه بسبب الضغوط الغربيه
على خلفيه تعزيز القدرات العسكريه على
اراضي الدول المجاوره الاعضاء في النيتو
مضيحه ان ذلك لا يتعارض مع احكام المادتين
الاولى والثانيه من معاهده الحد من انتشار
الاسلحه النوويه
ولفتت الخارجيه الى ان بيلاروسيا تتعرض
منذ سنتين ونصف السنه للضغوط غير مسبوقه
من جانب الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
وحلفائهما مندده بالتدخل في شؤون منسك
الداخليه اما الاتحاد الاوروبي توعد منسك
بعقوبات جديده في حال نشر هذه الاسلحه
خطوه كان قد تردد بها بوتين لكنه وبعد
اتخاذ القرار قال ان امريكا تفعل ذلك منذ
عقود ووفقا لمركز الحد من التسلح وعدم
الانتشار هناك نحو 100 سلاح نووي امريكي
مخزن في اوروبا عبر ست قواعد في خمس دول
وزير الدفاع الروسي
قال ان مجمعي الصناعات الدفاعيه في تشيل
يابسكراف سيزيدان انتاج القذائف والصواريخ
بنحو ثمانيه اضعاف بحلول نهايه العام
الحالي جاء ذلك خلال تفقده خطوط الانتاج
ومراقبه الجوده في المجمعين
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت اليوم ايضا ان
قواتها اسقطت صاروخا امريكيا بعيد المدى
من طراز جي ال اس دي بي في اول تاكيد على
تسلم اوكرانيا لاسلحه امريكيه جديده تسعى
من خلالها الى شن هجوم مضاد تستعد له
القوات الاوكرانيه وقالت الدفاع الروسيه
في بيان ان الصواريخ الامريكيه يصل مداها
الى 150 كلم
اعلنا وزير الدفاع الامريكي استون اليوم
ان بلاده لا تعتزم تزويد اوكرانيا
بالمسيره ام كيو 9 متعدده المهام جاء ذلك
ردا على سؤال احد المشرعين خلال جلسه
استماع امام لجنه القوات المسلحه
بالكونغرس
الخبران السابقان يطرحان تساؤلا هاما حول
مخزون سلاح واشنطن بدعمها لاوكرانيا هل
تستطيع امريكا تعويض نقص الصواريخ في
مخزونها بسبب ما تم ارساله لكياف حتى الان
الاجابه نعم لكن المده المتوقعه لذلك هي
اكثر من عقد في الاشهر العشره الاولى من
الحرب في اوكرانيا وافقت واشنطن على ثلاثه
وثلاثين مليار دولار من المساعدات
العسكريه لكياف الدعم شمله كميات او شمله
كميات ضخمه من صواريخ سنجر ما سبب نقصا في
المخزون الامريكي يتطلب تعويضه 13 عاما
بمستويات الانتاج العاليه الحاليه ايضا
ستحتاج المصانع الامريكيه لخمس سنوات
لسد النقص الذي سببه ارسال هذه الصواريخ
الى اوكرانيا السبب الرئيسيه لما يحدث هو
ان كياف تستهلك ذخائر اكثر من ما تنتجه
الولايات المتحده اذا قربنا الصوره اكثر
تنتج الولايات المتحده قذائف عيار 155 ملم
اي بمعدل 14 الف طلقه شهريا رقم ربما يبدو
كبيرا كانتاج شهري لكن خلال المعارك
استهلكت القوات الاوكرانيه انتاج شهر كامل
في يومين فقط الاضطراب في المخزون
الامريكي دفع واشنطن للتفكير بحلول من
بينها الاستعانه بالمخازن الامريكيه في
دول اخرى وتكثيف الانتاج بشكل عام لا تشهد
الولايات المتحده نقصا حادا في مخزون
اسلحتها وكحل الازمه اقترح البيت الابيض
هذا الشهر زياده بنسبه 51% في ميزانيه
شراء الصواريخ والذخائر مقارنه بالعام
الماضي لتصل الى 30 مليارا و600 مليون
دولار
اذا تحاول الولايات المتحده المساعده
لكنها تواجه نقصا في مخزونها بسبب
اوكرانيا التي تحتاج هي الاخرى للذخائر
بشكل كبير مثلا هي تطلق يوميا من 6000 الى
7000 قذيفه مدفعيه ما يجعل صناعه الذخائر
الاوروبيه مشاهدينا بحاجه الى استثمار
ملياري يورو في مصانع جديده لمواكبه
احتياجات اوكرانيا واحد من اكبر المصانع
الموجوده في النرويج يحاول بدوره مساعده
اوكرانيا لكن يواجهه عائق مختلف تخيلوا
العائق والتطبيق تيك توك
[موسيقى]
هذه الذخائر على المحاك والسبب هذه
المقاطع نعم مقاطع تيك توك قد تهدد تزويد
اوكرانيا بالذخائر شركه نامو لتصنيع
الذخائر النرويجيه احدى اكبر الشركات
المصنعه للذخيره في اوروبا قد لا تتمكن من
تلبيه طلب الاوكرانيين المتزايد على
الذخائر اما السبب فيعود لمركز بيانات تيك
توك الجديد الذي يحتكر ويستهلك الكهرباء
في المنطقه القريبه من اكبر مصنع ذخيره في
النرويج ووفق صحيفه
شركتنا مل التوسع تتعارض مع جهود تيك توك
لتحسين صورتها في مواجهه عدد متزايد من
عمليه الحظر في جميع انحاء العالم من خلال
استيعاب بيانات الاوروبيين محليا بشكل
اكبر من بينها النرويج اصلا
وهي خطوه تريد منها تيك توك ارضاء
المشرعين الاوروبيين بتخزين بيانات
المستخدم الاوروبي محليا وتقليل نقل
البيانات خارج المنطقه الشركه اعلنت عن
خطط لفتح مراكز بيانات جديده في ايرلندا
وفي منطقه هامار في النرويج الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه نامو القلق اعتبر ان النمو
المستقبل والحرب الدائره قد يعرقلهما
تخزين مقاطع الفيديو الخاصه بالقطط مثلا
لا حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من اوسلو
البروفيسور جلينديسين استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه جنوب شرق النرويج اهلا
بك معنا سيد جلين يعني اكبر مصانع السلاح
والذخيره في النرويج يواجه مشكله باحتكار
مركز كبير للبيانات من خلال الكهرباء
احتكار الكهرباء لتيك توك كيف يمكن حل هذه
المساله ان كان تقنيا او بالتعامل مع
التيك توك
الواقع ان المشكله تكمن في ان تيك توك قد
توصلت الى اتفاق يستهلك الكثير من الطاقه
وبالتالي فهذا يطرح اشكالا
الوضع السائد حاليا هو ان هذا المزود
التجاري يقول او انه يواجه ضغوط بسبب
استهلاك الطاقه لان الاولويه يجب ان تعطى
لصناعه الذخائر هذا هو الوضع السائد حاليا
والنرويج طبعا تشارك بنشاط في الحرب في
اوكرانيا من خلال تزويد الذخائر الى جانب
الولايات المتحده والغرب وهناك الكثير من
الدعايه المناهده للصين في الوقت الرائع
وتيك توك هدف لهذه الدعايه وبالتالي هناك
خطاب سائد مفاده انه يجب ان تبقى تيك توك
على الحياد حتى تتمكن الدول الغربيه من
تصنيع المزيد من الذخائر لتقدم الى
اوكرانيا نعم وبالتالي
كيف يمكن لتيك توك اذا كان الهدف هو
اقصائها او ابعادها الان عن المشهد في
اوروبا مشهد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي كيف
يمكن انها اعلنت عن خطط لفتح مراكز بيانات
جديده بايرلندا وفي منطقه هامار بن ناروش
يعني كيف يسمح لها بخطط توسعيه بالوقت
اللي الاتحاد الاوروبي طلب وحضر وجودها
النرويج ليست عضوا في الاتحاد الاوروبي
ولكن التيك توك شركه تستثمر في اوروبا
وهي لديها مشاريع
للتوسع هنا مستقبل تيك توك في اوروبا ليس
أكيدا بطبيعه الحال لان الولايات المتحده
تبذل قصار جهودها
للجعل كافه المنصات الصينيه محظوره حتى
تتمتع الولايات المتحده
باحتكار
والولايات المتحده تقول ان هناك استخدام
لبيانات المستخدمين من قبل سلطات الصينيه
هذه مشكله في الواقع
كافه منصات التواصل الاجتماعي وهذا هو ما
جعل تيك توك
تسعى لربما تمت الاسواق الاوروبيه من خلال
مراكز البيانات هذا هو تستثمر في اوروبا
حتى يظل لها وجود في القاره شكرا جزيلا
لكم
في جامعه جنوب شرق النارور شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
اذا بهذا الخبر العاج الخارجيه السعوديه
تقول بانه المملكه تدين الاقتحام السافر
لمستوطنين اسرائيليين لبحات المسجد الاقصى
متابعه في الاثناء استدعى الرئيس
الاسرائيلي اسحاق هتسوق ممثلين عن
الائتلاف الحاكم والمعارضه لبحث ازمه
التعديلات القضائيه قبل ذلك اكد زعيم
المعارضه
لحوار جدي لكن بشروط اول هذه الشروط
ويمنح للسياسيين ان لا يمنحهم القانون
سلطه اوسع على حساب القضاء والثاني هو عدم
وضع الاصلاحات القانونيه على جدول اعمال
الكنيست المعارضه حددت ممثليها للمفاوضات
لكن في المقابل لم يقم حزب الليكود الذي
يتزعمه نتنياهو بذات الامر
قبل ذلك ذكرت هيئه البث الاسرائيلي ان
وزير الدفاع المقال وفجلاند شارك في
اجتماع امني بحضور رئيس الوزراء بن ابي
نتنياهو مضيفه انا الاجتماع خصص لبحث
الاوضاع الامنيه وكان مساعدون لوزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي جالنت اكدوا انه ما زال
في منصبه حتى اشعار اخر ولم يتسلم خطاب
اقالته من جهه اخرى اكد نتنياهو في كلمه
لموظفي مكتبه انه سيخوض نقاشات مهمه
للتوصل الى اتفاقات حول التعديلات
القضائيه بعد عيد الفصح
وايضا بما يخص ما تقوله وتصرح عنه
الخارجيه السعوديه بما يخص اقتحام
مستوطنين اسرائيليين
بالاضافه الى ادانتها له تقول بانه
ممارسات هؤلاء المستوطنين تقود جهود
السلام
هجمت نائبه صحيفه هارت الاسرائيليه
التقارير عن صفقه بين رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ووزير الامن
القومي لتمار بن غفير ليوافق الاخير على
تاجيل خطه التعديلات القضائيه حزب القوه
اليهوديه بزعامه بن غفير اكد ان نتنياهو
سيؤجل خطته مقابل عرض تشكيل قوات حرس وطني
مدني تحت اشراف بن غفير فما هو هذا
التشكيل الجديد من المفترض ان يكون الحرس
الوطني جزءا من قوه حرس الحدود وذراعا
للشرطه الاسرائيليه بحسب الخطه
ستحول وحدات وتحول وحدات من حرس الحدود
الى فيلق للرد السريع في حاله الطوارئ
ومواجهه التهديدات الامنيه اين كان مصدرها
كما سيتم تجنيد الالاف من العناصر عناصر
الحرس الوطني لسيطره على الاضطرابات
العنيفه بحسب الخطه ما سيسمح للشرطه
بالتركيز على مهامها الروتينيه التقليديه
ايضا وفق الخطه سيتالف حرس الحدود من قوى
نظاميه واخرى احتياطيه اضافه لقوه من
المتطوعين من المدنيين والشرطه المعارضون
لفكره انشاء القوى الجديده يخشون من ان
تتحول لميليشيا خاصه بوزير الامن القومي
كما ينادي المعارضون بعدم انشاء كيان اخر
في دوله لديها الكثير من الاجهزه الامنيه
ايضا لديها وزراء داخليه ودفاع ومن قومه
في التشكيلات الوزاريه الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
التمار بن جبير يتولى منصب وزير الامن
القومي وهي تسميه مستحدثه لما كان يسمى
سابقا بوزير الشرطه صلاحيات بن جفير لا
علاقه لها بالجيش او وزاره الدفاع الجديد
ان اصبح مسؤولا عن الشرطه وحرس الحدود
وجزء من صلاحيات حرس الحدود الضفه الغربيه
التي يسيطر عليها الجيش الاسرائيلي ما خلق
حساسيه مع وزير الدفاع صاحب السيطره
الشامله على الضفه وزير الماليه
للدفاع بهذا يكون مسؤولا عما يسمى
بالاداره المدنيه للجيش الاسرائيلي رغم
هذا التعيين لم يمارس سموتريج صلاحياته
لان وزير الدفاع المستقيم منع تدخله في
شؤون الجيش
[موسيقى]
دخلنا مرحله جديده تابعنا
اهلا بكم من جديد القناه الافريقيه موطن
تنازع نفوذ ومصالح بين الولايات المتحده
والصين ومعظم دول القاره تحاول عدم
الانحياز لدوله على حساب الاخرى واشنطن
استخدمتا قوتهما لوضع اسس للتعاون في
مختلف المجالات مع دول افريقيه حاليا تقوم
نائبه الرئيس كما لهاريس بجوله في القاره
وفي وقت لاحق من العام يتوقع ان ياتي
الرئيس الامريكي نفسه هذه الزيارات تعكس
ادراكا متزايدا لحاجه الولايات المتحده
الى تعميق روابطها بالقاره اعتمادا على
الصداقه وليس الوصايه بدات حارس زيارتها
من خانه وفي عام 2022
صدرت الولايات المتحده الى غانا منتجات ب
800 مليون دولار اما غانا فكانت حصيله
صادراتها للولايات المتحده عن نفس الفتره
670 مليون دولار اكثر من نصف الرقم كان
للنفط الخام اذا انتقلنا للعلاقه
الاقتصاديه بين الصين وغانا فحجمها يزيد
بمقدار الضعف عما ذكرناه قبل قليل وارضاه
الصين لغانا العام الماضي تجاوزت سته
مليارات و800 مليون دولار في مواردات
الصين من غانا بلغت مليارا و300 مليون
دولار في الجانب السياسي تشدد الولايات
المتحده على قضيه الديمقراطيه في علاقاتها
مع الدول الافريقيه اما الصين فهي تنتهج
سياسه عدم التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه
للبلدان مهما كان شكل الحكم فيها
[موسيقى]
انا متحمسه جدا لمستقبل افريقيا انا
متحمسه جدا لتاثير مستقبل افريقيا على
بقيه العالم بما في ذلك الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عندما انظر الى ما يحدث في هذه
القاره حقيقه ان متوسط العمر هو 19 عاما
وما ينبئ به ذلك من نمو الفرص والابتكار
والامكانيات ارى في كل ذلك فرصه عظيمه ليس
فقط لشعوب هذه القاره ولكن لشعوب العالم
هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من القاهره
الدكتوره اماني الطويل مديره البرنامج
الافريقي في مركز الاهرام للدراسات اهلا
بك دكتوره اماني يعني كمالها ريس مثل ما
راينا بجوله افريقيه سبقها انتوني بلينكن
والرئيس الامريكي لاحقا هل ستستطيع واشنطن
تخطي النفوذ الصيني الاقتصادي الكبير في
القاره الافريقيه وما المعوقات امامها
اهلا بك والمشاهدين مساء الخير وكل عام
وانتم بخير الحقيقه تخطي الولايات المتحده
للمنجزات الصينيه في افريقيا صعب يعني يجب
ان تنتهج الولايات المتحده عملا جادا
ومتواصلا ازاء افريقيا لمده لا تقل عن خمس
سنوات متواصله المساله التانيه انه ايضا
على الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وده تحدي
كبير ان تتخلى عن فكره المشروطيات
والمشروطيات هنا لا تتعلق فقط بفكره
الحكم الرشيد ولكنها ايضا تتعلق باعاده
هيكله الاقتصادات الافريقيه
ونمو القطاع الخاص على حساب القطاع
المملوك للدوله او قطاع الاعمال العام ودي
سياسات بتساهم في زياده نسبه الفقر في
الكثير من الدول الافريقيه المس
انه على الولايات المتحده ان تنقل الى
الدول الافريقيه انهو او يعني
الكيفيه اللي
بتستخدم في التكنولوجيات المتقدمه ودي
مساله لن تضحي بها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
الخطاب الامريكي فيما يتعلق بالمستقبل
الافريقي هو خطاب الحقيقه مؤسس على فكره
على حاجتين الاستفاده من الموارد
الافريقيه الموارد الطبيعيه الافريقيه
ومحاوله ازاحه الصين المشكل ايضا امام
الولايات المتحده ان هناك تحالفا صينيا
روسيا في افريقيا
وهذا التحالف الحقيقه استطاع انه
يحرج دوله زي فرنسا مثلا في دول الساحل
والصحراء
فدي كلها مشكلات وتحديات تواجه واشنطن
ايذاء افريقيا وخصوصا انها لم تكن مخلصه
لافريقيا بشكل الكافي يعني في التسعينات
طرحت فكره الشراكه مع افريقيا على عهد
كلينتون ولم تدفع وراء اليات هذه الشراكه
الشراكه التجاريه ثم في 2003 او اربعه على
ما اذكر اعلنت اهميه قصوى لافريقيا في
الاستراتيجيات الامريكيه ولم تترجم هذه
الاهميه
لاليات ثم تم عقد قمتين يتيم يتيميه يعني
قيمتين فقط
امريكيه يتيمتين نعم قمتين فقط امريكيتين
مع افريقيا في 14
و22 بينما الصين تحافظ على قمه مشتركه مع
افريقيا دوريه فيما يعرف بالفكاه
منذ اكثر من عقد فعقدين تقريبا لانها من
الحقيقه تحتاج واشنطن الى فاعليه والى
تراكم والى اخلاص
وكل هذه الامور الحقيقه بتواجه تحدي
التخلي عن المشروطيات وده التحدي كبير
لانه في النهايه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تقدم نفسها للعالم على انها
حاميه للديمقراطيه نعم شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتوره اماني الطويل مديره البرنامج
الافريقي في مركز الاهرام للدراسات على
رايك
[موسيقى]
اعلنت منظمه الصحه العالميه توصياتها
بخصوص تطعيمات فيروس كورونا في مرحله
جديده من الجائحه المنظمه اشارت الى ان
الاطفال والمراهقين الاصحاء قد لا يحتاجون
بالضروره الى جرعه تطعيم لكن المجموعات
الاكبر سنا والمعرضه لخطر كبير يجب ان
تحصل على جرعه تطعيم معززه بين سته اشهر
الى 12 شهرا بعد اخر جرعه وذلك بناء على
عوامل مثل العمر والظروف المتعلقه
بالمناعه
[موسيقى]
فتحت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين ما يزيد عن 160
بابا للمسجد الحرام خلال شهر رمضان لدخول
وخروج المعتمرين والمصلين من اجل انسيابيه
حركتهم وعدم تعطلهم او تعثرهم فيما تقوم
اكثر من 27 جهه حكوميه وخاصه بدعم واسناد
داخل الحرم
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
هاني الصفيان اهلا بك هاني يعني انت حيث
تتواجد
بايجاز لو سمحت تحدثنا الان اذا عن فتح
160 بابا لتسهيل عبور وعدم تعثر المعتمرين
اخبرنا عن تلك الاجراءات بالتفاصيل نعم
نعم نحن في نقطه من النقاط الموجوده في
ساحات الحرم في المسجد الحرام في مكه
المكرمه وبالفعل ان هناك اكثر من 200
وعشره ابواب ولكن الان على مدار الساحه هي
الابواب التي تفتح هي قرابه المئه وستين
بابا نواب بالامكان ايضا فتح كافه الابواب
ولكن بحسب اعداد المعجبين والمصلين الذين
قدموا
رغبوا بالوصول الى المسجد الحرام والدخول
الى المسجد الحرام وكذلك ايضا الوصول الى
ساحاته ولكن هذه الصوره صوره سيابيه التي
الان موجوده في ساحات الحرم وايضا الصوره
تظهر
اماميه هو هي المسجد الحرام ونرى ايضا بعد
اداء المصلين لصلاه التراويح كيف هي كانت
عمليه الانسيابيه ولكن ايضا سوف ننتقل في
صوره اخرى ولكن ناخذ احد المعتمرين الذين
قدم من المغرب تونس مثل الخضراء تونس اهلا
وسهلا بك وحمدة ساسالكم سؤالين اولا كيف
ترى عمليه تنظيميه بما انك قدمت من تونس
وكيف ايضا وصلت الى السعوديه من اجل اداء
عمرتك والله هذا السنه كانت سنه خاصه يعني
انا اجلت اعديه من 21 اكثر من 21 سنه وكل
سنه كنت نجي على طريقه الوكالات الاصفار
هل السنه بالتسهيلات من المولى سبحانه ثم
من السعوديه ان وفرت التاشيره السياحيه
كانت الجايه على الطريقه السياحيه يعني
على التاشيره السياحيه يعني تاشيره لك
اسهل من انك
او تقدم على وكالات والله هي اسهل بحكم
الخبره ممكن 21 سنه الحمد لله انا اليوم
نظر هذا المبنى يعني كنت موجود 2002 يوم
ما كانوا اول ما ابدا يعني الحجر الاساس
موجود فيه يعني شكرا لك يعطيك العافيه اذا
ايضا من عمليات ايضا الخدمات الموجوده هنا
في ساحات الحرم احدى فرق الطبيه التابعه
لهيئه الهلال الاحمر السعوديه وكيف هي
مستعده ايضا من اجل اي حالات طارئه وايضا
لو نتقدم قليلا لنلتقط الصوره الاخيره هذه
هي الساحه ايضا من الساحات الحرم المكيه
خارج وايضا نلتقط هذه الصوره نعم تفضلي
انتهى وقتنا شكرا جزيلا لك ويعطيك الف
عافيه
صوره اليوم مشاهدينا لمحتاج فرنسي على
قانون رفع سن التقاعد يرفع اللافته كتب
عليها الماء يغلي عند 100 درجه مئويه اما
نحن فعند
49.3 في اشاره الى الماده الدستوريه التي
استخدمها ماكرون لتمرير القانون دون تصويت
البرلمان
تصريح اليوم هو للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
اسمي جو بايدن جئت هنا لانني سمعت بوجود
ايس كريم برقائق الشوكولا وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه انتقلت ببث عاجل للبيت الابيض
للاستمعي الى كلمات بايدن حول حادث اطلاق
النار في مدرسه ناجبيل بولايه تينيسي تحدث
بايدن فعلا لكن ماذا قال قال الكلمات التي
ذكرناها قبل قليل فهل ظل بايدن انه يتحدث
عما يحبه اطفال المدرسه التي وقع بها
الحادث
نكتفي بهذا القدر من الاخبار ولكن ملفات
العربيه
والضيوف مع الزميل صهيب شراير واخبار
الساعه مساء الخير يا صهيب مساء الخير
راويه رمضان كريم بالفعل جوله سريعه شامله
ومتنوعه من الاخبار بعد قليل في اخبار
الساعه في الصداره خبر الساعه يبقى
التظاهرات الاحتجاجيه في فرنسا على رفع سن
التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عاما
[موسيقى]